i mean tell me about the kansas city
chiefs just your takeaway right away
i i you know i'm one of those guys that
thought
the super bowl was gonna be a jump off
point to where it's gonna like take the
pressure and the shackles off them and
it's just gonna unleash
like this ultra confidence you know
let's let it fly and we're just going to
become greater type attitude from kansas
city
do you sense that what was your sense of
them overall as a team and where they're
at coming off the super bowl
peter just remember chris
they were behind by 24 to houston by
seven to tennessee and by 10 to san
francisco with eight minutes to go
so it's not like we're seeing the 27
yankees
or the 74 patriots or or
steelers rather or or whatever one of
these patriots teams
and again i think they're the best team
in football
right now but i also think that
this is going to be a weird year you
don't know how this can affect people
and
it in the two practices i saw
first of all sammy watkins has uh i
think it's a back
issue that has kept him out of some
practice so far uh
and although he's gonna return to
practice this week
the i watched tyreek hill go down with a
little bit of a tweet groin
and not go down but just sort of you
could tell that something happened on a
ball that he caught right
the only thing only point i'm making is
that when you have
a receiving core with a lot of these
finely tuned athletes you know who
who might get tweaks here and there
that's one of the reasons like i wrote
my column i said you know if
if if henry ruggs had fallen that
you know there was a decent shot that if
it was falling down
far enough that brett veach the gm of
the chiefs would have tried to trade for
him
trade up for him and i i which sounds
insane
but it is the truth the one other thing
i would say
chris everyone right now
is getting ready for their fantasy
drafts and
in i'll just give you a scene from both
days of camp
yeah go ahead i know where you're gonna
go or the first four snaps
of 11 on 11 offense defense
added practice first four snaps
on on uh wednesday all
hand-off handoffs to clyde edwards
hilaire
first three snaps on thursday
handoffs to clyde edwards hilaire also
on thursday
he ran a wheel route out of the
backfield
and the pass was behind him holmes threw
a pass pass was behind him
he caught it one-handed he brought it in
without even i mean it looked like
something he did in his sleep
so everybody who looks at the kansas
city chiefs this year it's
oh man there's not enough balls to go
around yeah
clyde edwards hilaire is not going to be
that great oh yeah
well just come to the games and remember
kareem hunt
week one yeah 2017. yeah 246 yards
against the new england patriots
and beating dante hightower on a wheel
right out of the backfield
for a 74-yard touchdown and he had a
fumble early in that game but andy reid
still had
faith in him i remember first kerry yeah
and he had never fumbled like at all in
his college career it was the first time
in years that he had put the ball on the
ground but edward hillaire is a guy now
the cat's out of the back you've written
about it chris and i have been talking
about clyde over slayer the entire i
feel like we're almost maybe propping
the guy up too much
but i i don't think it's it's
unjustified when you consider you're
plugging him into that offense damian
williams the starting running back from
last year has opted out for the entire
season
this is the clyde edwards hilaire show
and even though andy reid doesn't have a
reputation
for three yards and a cloud of dust if
he has a guy who can
do it and the defenses are keeping
everyone deep
to not be burned by tyree kill and sammy
watkins and the opening is there
at some point you're gonna just run the
ball right peter
one of the interesting things and chris
you would you would understand
exactly you know because you've
obviously studied offenses
intricately but i found
you know as somebody who knows andy reid
very well
told me that i said how will my homes be
different this year
and you know because i asked mahomes
okay what did you work on this off
season he goes you know
making quicker decisions recognizing
defenses
quicker and that just comes with age and
experience
but the interesting thing about the read
offense
is that he's got so many tributaries off
every play right he can run them in
different ways
like i saw a bunch formation a tight
bunch formation with hill hardman demar
demarcus robinson and on one of the
snaps
okay clyde edwards hilaire went into
like
jet motion across the rear of the
formation
and he almost ran out of bounds you know
he stopped almost right at the sidelines
and i'm watching that and then the next
one
he runs is same kind of formation right
you know with that bunch and he just ran
a little wheel ride out of the backfield
so what i'm what i'm saying is all these
plays
and he's not alone andy reid's not alone
everybody in the nfl does this
but it's really noticeable
and on one deep throw to tyreek hill
that i saw on wednesday
the secondary you could tell this is the
number one secondary they're pointing
here there everywhere
and and and tyree kill just zooms by
bashad breland
and it's an easy touchdown for mahomes
and look
everybody has spent the offseason
studying the kansas city chiefs
all i know is that i know reid
he's studying ways to look a little bit
different
in 2020. hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports